so i saw people shot in the streets and
running and
seeking help
but i think those
those
i don't know if i can visualize them
those things
had an effect on me
[Music]
when i was born in bangladesh a country
at that time was called east pakistan
in 1971 there was a war of independence
so i was about 11 or 12 at that time but
my upbringing in terms of education was
highly disrupted
because of that war
my own brother my elder brother being
killed whom i saw die in front of my own
eyes
and 22 other relatives were killed in
that
violence but at that young age 11 12 13
up to about 16
he was always fighting and killing and
people dying around your death
so i saw people shot in the streets and
running and
seeking help
conflict on both sides nobody is to be
blamed i think on looking back but i
think those
those uh
i don't know if i can visualize them
those things
had an effect on me
when did you leave and
come to the uk
yes so i went to college and i was 17
and by the time i was about 17 and a
half my father had come to this country
he was supported
to come here as an asylum seeker refugee
i mean i don't know the exact status but
he fled so when i went to university
that's where i was if i can use the word
radicalized i don't if i was radicalized
or not
because i was always
prone to such thinking or amenable to
such thoughts
and there were people from mainly the
muslim brotherhood
who had the influence on me in the
political direction
talking will get you nowhere so we are
having to do two things one become more
alert to your reality secondly
this reality will not change by being
part of the status quo you have to fight
back
as a young person i wanted to be
meaningful
i wanted to contribute in a way
that made real change not just talk
because politics is too long-winded and
i don't understand and there's there is
hypocrisy and double standard even at
that age we understood this it wasn't
all i'm a good muslim and you know i
want to you know make the islam great it
was more like well you are cowards i'm a
brave person there's a fight in
palestine and they're the underlings
and i can fight
so
when islam was added to the equation of
course it kind of had a very potent mix
so i felt
enthused i felt i was doing the right
thing because it is after all
in support of those who are victimized
or
the victims
and that at that age i didn't understand
that there's another another narrative
there's another side to the story that
the the reality is much more complicated
if not confusing
that others other people others i mean
non-palestinians non-muslims in general
people human beings have rights feelings
you know there was an argument going
back perhaps several thousand years
about palestine so i worked for first 20
years in my organization from the age of
21
to about 40 years old without pay every
weekend
it's a lot of hard work to not only
bring people to a political awareness
but to infuse them to say
politics is not the way the way is jihad
to fight back
where did your fight for jihad take you
what sort of countries did you end up
travelling to
when i
got involved in the physical fighting it
wasn't as easy as today when you can
just hop on a plane go off to say turkey
and then across the border you have
you had to go through a lot of loopholes
rigmarole
so for in my case i had a person come
over from germany
to vet me to make sure that i am not a
fake or a dangerous person to them so i
was vetted first then go to amsterdam
and then i'm vetted again and this local
imadu din bakri who was a veteran from
the afghan jihad then gives me a letter
of approval i take that letter then i
fly off to peshawar in pakistan
having the contact then i make my way to
the camp in pakistan
and then they check the letter then
welcome me in and i'm a prized person
because i'm british
i speak english and it has always more
kind of
an all around your head for some reason
you walk around with the halo because
you speak english and you know you can
bring more benefit in some ways i don't
know how
what was the camp like when you arrived
camp was wonderful if i can really
project my mind back i will never forget
the brotherhood the sense of relief
so warm welcoming
and it's almost like a holiday camp but
it's all men they're not a single female
inside
and and you feel
with the people because they're all
there for the one thing
and they have no worldly motives um guns
are around as well so the excitement and
thrill i suppose in a boyish manner
you know the guns and stuff
they look after you give you food
there's brotherhood meaning you're
sitting together prayers are there
eating
sleeping rough but it's fun you go out
local whatever shopping for
camouflage gear whatever
so i think the excitement the glamour
those things were also there in those
days in in its own ways
they're much more glamorized today
so that was my feeling so i came back
really uplifted
and i felt this is it i've found the
true muslims they don't they're not
running after the world and they're
spending their lives working all the
time and paying bills and all the
headaches
so was it a form of escapism for many
people i never questioned it was for me
a relief
and who are you fighting against in
afghanistan
and my biggest mistake i think was to
presume i was fighting against
non-muslim enemies
just because they're non-muslims that's
not that's not the reason why they
should be anybody should be fought i
mean that's not islam teaches at all but
i went there to fight against the
communists because by definition to me
on paper communists are godless people
they don't believe in god or religion
so as an outsider i shouldn't have gone
even if it was so-called jihad
but the point was this it was wrong
because you ended up fighting muslims
against muslims and both sides had
something valid or
intelligent to say about what they
wanted in life
basically they want food and land
when did you realize you know what you
were doing was wrong and when did your
ideas shift
burma my last experience when i left i
looked at the commander
and he was videotaping everything for
propaganda purposes
not only did i find out that that camp
of the leader was actually going to have
after i left a meeting with the fbi
so i'm saying why am i serving these
organizations raising funds in britain
when they are part of the global
politics
what's the effect on the local people
the local people
want to just live ten thousand pounds
even fifty thousand hundred thousand
pounds we have given at one go
ten thousand pounds is like the entire
village can live for a whole month
happily you know in their kind of rural
environment
i bring that amount of money give it to
the leaders what are they doing so it's
not that they are stealing the money but
hey the leader's son is studying degree
in malaysia being privately funded for
the money we gave
but what has it done to local people
they are still in the poverty no
improvement in their lifestyles there's
discrimination meaning the upper
echelons still have the um
the lion's share of everything food
housing bulletproof cars
but then you find local boys from my
group went out and killed three or two
or three other local boys who was in
another outfit both fighting for the
same cause against the same enemy with
the same islam with the same rallying
calls but the local people they don't
move
you can't incite them to fight they
don't want to fight they just want to
have a common life
why can't we give them a political
solution
uh
you said earlier you didn't have the
intention to kill innocent people so can
you just clarify for me what the
difference is between the kind of
jihadism you were part of and the more
modern day jihadism where we see
terrorists going and blowing up music
venues and killing innocent people
today's kill people is driven by hatred
blind hatred no discrimination between
those who are in uniform fighting you
those who are in uniform off duty and
let alone those who are not in uniform
at all you know in in no security
apparatus
and then again then you target innocent
the most innocent of people
from beslan school siege to the bali
bombing and you name it the catalog will
go on and on for a very long time
you know and we can press into service
all sorts of grievances and talk about
how maybe they are so provoked they are
so undermined they are become so
desperate
but what happened to the religion then
then don't bring religion into it i beat
myself up inside me and then i try to
make up for the evil i have caused
or to stop people going down that evil
or wickedness or ignorance
with the work that i do a young man
comes up to me after friday prayers i
did the sermon at wembley central mosque
i do the sermon and he said several
years back he walks up to me and said
sheikh called me shakes this is a term
of respect sheikh
after the my friday sermon um i saw your
film i've decided not to go to syria
anymore
whoa
no no need to rede-radicalize refer you
to prevent channel
you just heard a talk on channel 4 itv
or something and he felt i spoke the
truth as an older man
that's it
if you could send a message to people
considering becoming a jihadist what
would that be
on a serious note if i could uh if
anybody cares to listen and at least
explore what i'm trying to say
i would say you know give up dogmatism
try to find out how you know the truth
try to understand the local politics the
people the culture don't interfere
sometimes without knowing what you are
trying to do you interfere and cause
more harm
sincerity does not excuse the person
and justify the person doing reckless
irresponsible actions
[Music]
you know one thing you should know about
espionage as well as bomb making
the first mistake is your last mistake
you're not going to live to make another
mistake and therefore you have to be
absolutely careful you know one wrong
word you know and you are
a head shorter and six feet under